oh my god
looks like some kind of detonator why
would they give us the detonator to our
own bomb tonight you're all gonna be a
part of a social experiment I'm ready
right now to blow you all Stein Liberty
come in over anyone attempts to get off
their boat you all die each of you has a
remote blow up the other boat at
midnight I blow you all up if however
one of you presses the button I'll let
them live so who's it gonna be Harvey
Dent's most wanted scumbag collection or
to see innocent civilians you choose oh
and you might wanna decide quickly
because the people on the other boat may
not be quite so noble
the belt seen in the dark night is a
great example of game theory
specifically it's an example of the
prisoner's dilemma a situation in which
each of two parties would be better off
cooperating with the other but each is
also tempted to betray and so they end
up in a situation where both betray each
other I'm not going to explain the
prisoner's dilemma if you haven't heard
of it yet you should watch my video
which is linked here right now I'm going
to explain why the boat scene is a
prisoner's dilemma and why each boat is
tempted to detonate the bomb and the
other boat the rules the Joker setup are
as follows
he says that if both boats try and
cooperate and don't blow the other one
up then he's going to take matters into
his own hand and blow everyone up at
midnight however he is going to offer
them a chance to survive if exactly one
boat detonates the bomb then he'll let
that boat live and the final situation
is that if both boats detonate the bomb
then obviously both boats are gonna be
blown up we can think about the payoffs
in terms of a game theory matrix we have
two boats boat one in boat two that can
either cooperate or detonate the bomb if
they both detonate the bomb then they
both end up blown up if only one boat
detonates the bomb then that boat gets
to survive while the other boat gets
blown up and in some ways this is worse
the boat that tried to cooperate feels
like a fool for doing that the final
situation is if both boats cooperate now
they still end up being blown up by the
Joker but in some ways this is best for
the group because it shows that neither
was willing to kill the other however as
we can see from these from the payouts
if boat two no matter what bowed to does
it's clearly better for boat one to
detonate the bomb and similarly no
matter what boat one does it's better
for boat two to
Nathe the bomb so both votes are
attempted to detonate the bomb and this
is the outcome that the Joker wants to
achieve as we see in the dark night
neither boat was willing to detonate the
bomb and kill the other boat so it
turned out that the Joker did
miscalculate the goodness of people and
in this situation the prisoner's dilemma
can be beaten I hope you enjoyed this
video please subscribe to my channel you
can also follow me on my blog bind your
decisions or on twitter at pressure
locker or get my books at Amazon